Walter burns where did you get the idea
of writing a book called making Patriots
where did I get the idea
I suppose when I begun to reflect on
such things as parades in the city of
Chicago when I was a youth and I began
to think that there were more Patriots
and receiving a better patriotic
education when I was young then young
people are today and I began to reflect
on the absence of any kind of patriotic
education in the Universities where I
spent most of my life that's an answer
how long were you in Chicago well I was
born in Chicago a long time ago as I say
in the book one of my earliest memories
was watching a patriotic parades on
Memorial Day
Michigan Avenue and to give you an idea
how old I am I can remember the
survivors of Union Army walking down
Michigan have you struggling to him that
she can have him with their standards
and the bands playing and so forth
that was something in the late 20s there
were still soldiers alive at that time
where'd you go to school or luncheon
College the city of Chicago and I went
to the University of Iowa and then reen
college out in Portland Oregon for one
year then the London School of Economics
and then back to the University of
Chicago for three or four or five years
to get my PhD you spent time in the
service at all yourself oh yes so yes
from the very beginning of the war to
the end of the war in the Navy my father
was in the Army in World War one and he
saw to it that I went into the Navy the
second war why do you think that your
Patriots your patriotism is is not as
visible as it used to be well it has a
great deal to do with education and what
I want young people today are not taught
they're taught social studies rather
than American history they have no
knowledge I think of an
of the the founders in this country they
don't need biographies and some of the
polls reflect or review a shocking
ignorance of historical events one of
them something to the effect that only
half the people in high school today can
place the civil war within 10 years of
its actual time it's hard to believe
isn't it but the polls do this and say
it discovered it why is this happening
why is it happening why didn't it happen
in my day I may be as a citizen of
Chicago Illinois I may have been more
aware of Lincoln than people elsewhere
because Lincoln of course was a citizen
of the state of Illinois and very much a
figure in in Illinois and of course a
figure in my in my education we we were
expected to memorize such things as the
Gettysburg Address and that's just like
the Shakespeare sonnet that was part of
the education and that doesn't happen
nowadays I think and then as to the
particular situation now surely the
Vietnam War had something to do with our
present condition we didn't have a
Vietnam War when I was growing up we had
World War one and then of course the
spanish-american war which was not
really much of a war and the civil war
the Civil War was very much a part of
our life I mentioned in the book the the
state song of Illinois unlike most
states songs that really does focus on
the Civil War again perhaps because of
Lincoln and Grant after how he came from
Galena Illinois and Logan and when the
southern host came through pitting gray
against the blue there were none more
brave than you Illinois Illinois we sang
that was the state song we don't do that
anymore I guess do you have to have war
to have patriotism that was the question
I hope you wouldn't ask because of
course it reflects on our present
situation do we need another war in
order to
and to revive patriotism I'll answer to
this extent it sure helps if it's a good
war unlike the Vietnam War so what
happens to us if we don't have
patriotism as a country well of course
if we don't have to fake it isn't if we
don't have wars we don't need Patriots
patriotism so much on the other hand we
still we still need Patriots who think
of the country and think of their fellow
citizens and are willing to make
sacrifices for their fellow citizens
even if they're not in war time we need
public spiritedness and a war of course
is a a great way of inculcating that
it's interesting that lincoln understood
that too in this that final paragraph of
his first inaugural most of which is
trying to persuade the south in the
southern states not to secede from the
union agains up by I'm loath to close we
are not enemies we are friends we are
not enemies we must not be enemies
passion may have strained but must not
break our bonds of affection the mystic
chords of memory stretching from every
battlefield and Patriot grave to every
living heart and hearthstone all over
this broad land will yet swell the
chorus of the Union when when they had
touched as they will be touched by the
better angels of our nature
I hope that in this context because of
course he says memories of battlefields
and patriots graves relying on them and
none of course fact means the wars and
of course what he did was to use the
Gettysburg use the graves and Gettysburg
to swell the course of the Union where
did you or when did you memorize that
the Gettysburg Address I memorized when
I was a schoolboy but this this other
one I don't know that I have memorized
it I've come close to it I just I'm just
struck by it's such a beautiful passage
and it's such an unlikely statement to
be made very a President of the United
States and only a Lincoln could do it
and then only ins under certain
circumstances the interesting thing
about Lincoln is even when it was 28
years of old and made that speech to the
young men's Lyceum of Springfield a
speech entitled the perpetuation of our
political institutions he knew that
these institutions were threatened and
might not be perpetuated and he set out
to understand the threat and then to
figure out how they might be perpetuated
and as I I do in the book I put that
speech that early speech with this last
paragraph of the first inaugural and
then the Gettysburg Address
it's all they fit together you know the
legend is that he he scribbled the
Gettysburg Address on the back of an
envelope on a train going to Gettysburg
that's that could be true but if he had
been thinking about this literally
thinking about it for years
and it didn't the Gettysburg Address
simply didn't come out of the tip of his
tongue at the last moment how long have
you been thinking about making Patriots
this book not so long but what led up to
it the background and the information I
wrote in a preface to a book that I
published about a dozen years ago
something to the affirming effect like
movie is mischief what was his
neighborhood and to be reminded they was
down wasn't it had to be reminded he was
speaking prose all his life I had come
to realize finally I'd then all my
political career been writing a defense
of liberal democracy of American liberal
democracy so this book is merely a
continuation of other books I've written
and the way it's it's it's my career as
a university professor where did you
teach mostly Cornell I ended up here at
Georgetown University professor but
Cornell was principally where I thought
and what did you teach at Cornell the
Constitution of the United States like
other colleagues in the department with
each one of us had to teach a
introduction to American government but
then we went off in our special ways in
my special ways was the Constitution of
the United States and I taught that in
our top courses on Abraham Lincoln
horses on the founding of the United
States which I talked twice at the
University of Chicago when I went there
especially for that purpose one of the
things I did when I read your book was
write down almost every name that you
mentioned from Rousseau to Socrates
names of people that had something to do
with what our founders here had read and
Aldo kept to speak and I want to ask you
about them Rousseau comes up a lot who
was he and what impact has he had on
what we are as a country a little in
impact directly the first place
wondering what he was was a political
philosopher in the 18th century and he
reflected on the modern thought for
example thought of the Enlightenment
Hobbes and Locke and he had some
misgivings about their own understanding
of these things and wanted about whether
it would finally succeed and among other
things he he thought about religion what
about the the difficulty that religion
had posed and for example especially in
the 17th century England they were there
just Wars of civil wars there and he
concluded that what was needed was a
civil religion and their way is a
religion without priests and my Civil
originally meant a religion that
something like the ancient Athens and
Sparta had their own gods and he saw
that as a kind of solution to
whether it be no contest between that
which is gods and that which is the
states and put them together and I quote
him to that effect and use them for my
purpose who followed him well in a way
it's I'd have to go back and what
preceded her who preceded him for our
pervs that John Locke preceded him and
John Locke was the principal political
philosopher who influenced the
Declaration of Independence for example
and certainly influenced our thought on
the division of church and state he
wrote a very influential piece on
toleration that Jefferson quoted and
Jefferson wrote no notes in the margin
of it and interesting enough his notes
and the margin Locke's letter on
toleration are still extant we can we
can find them and his reflections on
Locke's Leonard on toleration found
their way into the famous Virginia
statute on religious freedom which is a
major Bernard Bailyn thinks that's the
major historical document in our history
and as much to be said for that I myself
would say Declaration of Independence
but a strong case we made for this
Virginia statute because our separation
of church and state is is surely a major
aspect of American principles when we
say as we do on every dollar bill on
Novus Ordo seclorum the order of the
ages what we really mean by that I think
is largely separation of church and
state
well John Locke lived when where did he
come from 17th century English political
philosopher
wrote for our purposes something called
the second treatise of civil government
which certain phrases from that treatise
are to be found in the Declaration of
Independence
Americans caught at a time and again he
in a way is the political philosopher
underlying our Constitution and
Declaration of Independence
who else would Thomas Jefferson and
James Madison and these folks have read
oh wow they they would have read
Montesquieu and they referred to him as
the celebrated Montesquieu here this is
an eighteenth-century Frenchman somewhat
earlier than result the he wrote the
spirit of the laws and there certainly
section of that talked about the
separation of powers and we reflected on
that do you think for instance at James
Madison read Montesquieu and well I mean
read Eamon said yeah that's the way I
think and then just you found his
Montesquieu's thesis right into the
Constitution though whether he said
that's the way I think that's hard to
say but there's no question but that
noticed you influenced him as well as
others Hamilton for example oh sure they
they read these people and they
reflected on them took some things that
they wrote and discarded other things I
suppose but largely in terms of
principles they accepted Locke's
treatise for example what about resale
did what he live well who sold died just
before our Declaration of Independence
so he didn't really figure that much but
he did reflect on modern principles of
political philosophy and an example cast
some doubt about the the possibility of
a decent government being established on
those principles and he has a much more
influence on people today than I think
he did at the beginning he for example
coined the term bushwa as we understand
it and when our academics speak
contemptuously
our our painters and writers be
contemptuously at the bush y'see their
speaking and whistles turns we so
understood the British well of course
the term itself was an old term but
bushwalk Everett Rousseau gave me this
modern meaning a person who takes care
of himself thinks only of his own
business and doesn't take care of the
public good and when we complain about
our capitalists who sell things to China
when we were concerned about selling
secrets defense secrets to China we to
some extent rely on hundra so because he
anticipated that sort of thing as as
marks and marks followed him but then in
many ways Marx was influenced by
Rousseau I'll just leave out that what
do you think of Karl Marx Karl Marx was
a major figure and a major thinker
it was also wrong it was you know
seriously wrong when he thought that
nothing happens by chance in history and
it was inevitable that just as a never
moment that the communist revolution
would supersede the feudalism and due
course see bosom was a thing of the past
and then the socialism was superseded
liberal democracy and capitalism and in
due course the social state was wit
would wither away and this is all laws
of history well it didn't work out that
way
I mean the Soviet Union which was the
was the socialist state products alone
didn't wither away it just simply
collapsed out of its own contradictions
know what what do I think of Karl Marx
it's not sufficient simply to say that
he was an evil man because I thought he
wasn't an evil man
lots of people people picked him up and
used him and Stalin was an evil man but
Marx wasn't Marcia was a major thinker
he was simply wrong in certain respects
besides what I think about Marx doesn't
make any difference
why not this irrelevant Marxist Maori
irrelevant Marxism is dead but for how
long was he relevant well further a
large part of the 19th century and well
into the 20th century and we of course
fought a cold war the consequence of
which was we put an end to Marxism what
would you like to have your students who
you you have any idea how my students
you've taught in her life thousands if
you count people in the introductory
courses for example number 101
the Cornell there would be well over 100
oh well over 100 and I used to have a
little over a hundred in the
constitutional law at Cornell how many
years weird crap
Tim as a matter of fact that interesting
experience when Janet Reno was appointed
attorney general of the United States
she went back to Cornell and I hadn't
known that she was the Cornell student
but she went back in Cornell and said
something about how much she was
influenced especially about two people
one chap and literature then we and I've
never and wasn't aware that I had heard
her in a car locked class but I kept all
my course records in part because I mean
four years was being asked to write
letters of recommendation to students I
simply kept them and I looked back in
the 1959 land deed was Janet Reno she
was a good student but I could remember
which I found strange because the idea
of a six-foot two-inch woman
even in the large class of a hundred
students I ought to have remembered her
but I didn't but there she was what it
what would you want the students that
you talked to say about you about me
about you and the way you taught that
would make you the happiest that I had
given them reasons to love this country
I think why why is that the motivator
for you well I thought as I say in the
book the United States or America is the
one essential country and I quote blink
in the course as the last best hope of
Earth and he thought that was so and I
think it's so and we are as I say the
one essential country we had to defeat
the fascists and the Nazis in World War
two and it was large and I are doing
that that victory was won Britain could
have done could not have done it alone
and we were essential in in the Cold War
and I think we're still essential in two
respects one to deserve as a model of a
liberal democracy and then secondly to
defend liberal market the liberal
democracy around the world and that we
have to do and we're constantly given
examples of that answer the constant
battle to an extent do we get involved
in Kosovo and so forth and I can
understand all the reasons why we might
not want to do so currently the one is
Macedonia with the Albania in the fights
there all kinds of reason why we should
not get involved in that and of course
the argument is to what extent is our
national interest involved in it but in
a way our national interest is involved
where ever liberal democracy exists and
wherever it's threatened it's
interesting that
what 12 13 years ago two gentleman
square and the Chinese thing they were
they built the Statue of Liberty modeled
after ours
that's it that's interesting these
Chinese students there was a I gathered
there was a discussion as to whether the
human figure should the Chinese with EXO
can't the guys or Western eyes and was
decided read didn't make any difference
and it didn't of course but I just find
it interesting that the that our
influence there is reflected in this
simple fact of the Statue of Liberty and
you know we got the Statue of Liberty
from the French oh yes I know the
replica of the Senate I know the reason
I bring it if you think they have any do
we have any more claim to democracy and
freedom than the French Dip oh sure oh
sure
there's an old joke evolving an American
in Paris well familiar with Paris has to
go someplace it goes to the head of the
taxi queue and opens the door and says
got an or whatever and the cab driver
didn't want to go there at that time of
day and he goes down the whole line no
cab driver will take him there anything
at the last station he says this is the
sort of attitude of the put the end to
the third be public and the cab driver
says there'll be a fourth now there
bring it up today they'll be a sixth or
a fifth or a sixth if you if you look at
the trench histories since their
revolution which more or less the same
time as ours we've had one great
struggle the Civil War course but one
Constitution really you tell story about
going to Brazil back you know it 1987
you know it was interesting but why were
you there then I've been invited to
lecture on constitutionalism at a time
when they and overthrown and some
military military rulers and they were
beginning to talk about a constitution
how to write a constitution what was
essential in the writing a constitution
so I was there as someone coming from
the United States this one place and
university received me I had finished
and somebody got up and some and
denounced not me but the chap who would
invited me
local Brazilian why don't you invite an
American he said they've had only one
Constitution why didn't you buy invited
Bolivian they've had a hundred this is
they've had great experience in hiding a
constitution therefore get someone from
that place and I enjoyed that story
because of course the essential thing is
to concentrate on our success and
whether our success might be a model for
the Brazilians and we really have had
only one Constitution why do you think
that's the case in part because a it's a
good Constitution be we were the
Tocqueville makes this point of course
we were not surrounded by enemies
powerful enemies and compare our
geographical situation would say Poland
Russians on one side and Germans on the
other and throughout the greater part of
our history we we simply didn't have
that those kind of enemies on our
borders secondly or thirdly we had a
great country a great continent which
was rich and we could reap it's we wore
rewards but mostly as what I started
with it's a good Constitution is written
by people who understood politics
understood modern politics understood
human beings what moves them and young
men of course were lucky don't feel made
that point to they said the new
Americans are lucky were born equal
instead of having how does it go you're
born equal instead of becoming so
comparing us with the French what he
meant by that
the this really does answer your lyric
your first question having to do with
the French Revolution the after the
French Revolution there were aristocrats
some monarchs descendants of monarchs
and a whole body of aristocrats who had
been dispossessed of their place and
their property and were selling it were
anxious to come back and regain a place
and they made that effort for a large
part of the 19th century whereas we were
born equal or without becoming so there
were some aristocrats here they went
back to England some some of the Tories
others went to Canada Nova Scotia and
New Brunswick sort of territory was
really made for them but they were few
in number relatively speaking and they
left and then the only people left were
we Democrats and that made a difference
if you're a black American watching this
you would say we didn't get that deal
that's true and it took a long time and
that of course is the is the major
aspect of our history and I think it's
important for students to go back and
understand that issue as it wasn't the
beginning see the difficulties had
caused and and see how that problem was
overcome the Constitution you know
doesn't use the word slavery doesn't
appear in the Constitution until the
13th amendment abolishing it Frederick
Douglass understood this very well and
understood the difficulties of
overcoming that original sentiment
originally you know there's no real
there's really no doubt about this
everybody including leading southerners
were anti-slavery they understood the
incompatibility of slavery and the
principles of the Declaration of
Independence Thomas Jefferson for
example understood this very well indeed
unfortunately Jefferson really did
nothing to overcome it Washington Frieda
slaves and had it not been for the
cotton gin and it had not been for the
opening up of the western lands making
slavery possible making cotton possible
there well I you know I do think it's
necessary for us to go back and read
that history to understand the
incompatibility of the principles and
what happened and the difficulty of
overcoming slavery for example how many
of us appreciate the difficulty the
founders had people are then sometimes
condemned the founders for not
abolishing slavery or for accepting the
Constitution without abolishing slavery
well had they done what modern critics
say there would have been two united
states one the united states of southern
america call it the Confederate States
of America and then the United States
and what would have been because the
closest is that almost all the black
people in this country at that time 90
some odd percent of them lived in the
south and almost all of them were slaves
there what was hope for them hope
consistent in the Union and the the
founders understood that and Lincoln
understood that so that he sometimes has
are condemned for saying that his first
task was to preserve the Union and
secondly to emancipate slaves he
understood very well and Frederick
Douglass understood this very well the
conditions for emancipation was the you
if the Confederate States of America in
1860 and been allowed to go the wrong
way as a Confederate states in 1787 have
gone one way their slavery would have
been a part of that original
Constitution and there was really little
hope for emancipation in those
conditions and first you preserve the
Union first you get the Union 1787 with
the prospect that in due course they
will be abolished and then in 1860 and
1565 preserved the Union as a condition
of emancipating slaves that was true how
much of what's happened in our country
can the white person take credit for
versus the black like Frederick Douglass
and many others Sojourner Truth I to be
Wells is up to Martin Luther King I mean
if the black hadn't agitated for their
freedom do you think the whites would
have ever given it to him probably no
but a condition of their agitation
really was that the principles of the
Declaration you know something Martin
Luther King jr. for example it's not by
chance that he delivered his great
speech on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial where one other place in this
country was an appropriate for him to
make that speech there and of course to
think of Lincoln listen think of the
Declaration of Independence he made a
career in that what he opens as the the
Gettysburg Address was saying four score
and seven years ago well he was speaking
1863 1863 - four score in the 787 is
1776 got suspect 1776 those principles
its those principles that that they're
anti-slavery principles and they were
violated and forgotten in the beginning
or certainly violated and there was a
prospect that they would be violated
again especially in the 1850s
Stephen Douglas Villa Illinois was
largely responsible for the
kansas-nebraska Act which opened up
these western territories to slavery by
with under the principle of popular
sovereignty and Lincoln assistant if you
say popular sovereignty which is to say
you allow the people the territories to
be free or slave that's a violation of
the principle of the Declaration and he
would not stand for it and he wouldn't
went back into politics because of it
and he fought it it became president
because of it
and he fought the civil war because of
it and he won the Civil War and the
result was the freedom we have now you
asked me when slavery has been abolished
without the the agitation of the black
people I said probably not on the other
hand there were all kinds of people in
this country who who were agitating to
abolish slavery just think of the those
people in New England William Lloyd
Garrison and the others who beginning in
the 1840s and culminating in the 1850s
were anti-slavery people and they played
a major role in the emancipation and
they were and they were white people go
again at all your lists of thinkers and
we haven't you know Edmund Burke and
Martin Luther and Horace Greeley I've
just written down everybody that's that
I could that you wrote about from you
mentioned Alexander Hamilton and
Jefferson Davis and Henry Clay and
Thomas Paine and Adam Smith all these
people who if you had to put your finger
on one or two of them who have had more
impact on things like what got us to
where it's a freer country today than
say it was two hundred twenty years ago
basic principles that allow the
Constitution to live who would it be in
history Madison Shirley
he's known rightly as the father of the
Constitution and he's also the father of
the Bill of Rights and is largely his
doing that the Bill of Rights was
adopted later on Hamilton because of his
influence over economic matters you know
Hamilton is largely forgotten in this
city there's no great monument the
Hamilton there's a statue of him outside
the treasury building rather than that
the no great monument whereas Jeffers is
all over the place but Hamilton was a
great soldier he hadn't played a major
role in the the theme of the British in
the Battle of Yorktown the last battle
and of course he was a major figure in
the first administration of George
Washington sitting down the terms of the
brita the the American economy really
and that's hasn't a lot to do with our
subsequent history or our subsequent
prosperity but back up from that though
I mean James Madison who's the greatest
influence on James Madison ah what the
SELEX does Locke surely did Locke get it
the original with him well certain
things came from Hobbes tell his Hobbes
when did he live fifty years or so
before luck he wrote in the early part
of the 17th century and he was a Hobbs
really was an originator and it was you
know what it was Hobbes followed by
Locke who talked about the state of
nature and the rights that men enjoy
natural rights in the state of nature
how it's necessary to leave the state of
nature for civil society and which is
done by a contract all that is American
doctrine but all of that comes from
directly from from from Locke but
indirectly from Hobbes where did Hobbes
live well he lived he was an Englishman
are there others other English one other
anybody's that you think that but behind
all these words well to some extent
David Hume Wisconsin had a great deal to
do with commercial activities as did
Adam Smith and Anna Smith great work The
Wealth of Nations was published the same
years 1776 is our constant our
Declaration of Independence and these
people had read Smith it studied Smith
when did he live well the latter part of
the 18th century into the early 19th
century another Scotsman what about
Thomas Paine what do you think his role
has been in all this well he was a great
sense journalist John Adamson liked him
he was a propagandist and there's no
denying that his book common sense I
mentioned in my book how many copies had
sold an exceedingly large number of copy
over a hundred thousand copies I think
which was a large number of but you know
there's only a little pamphlet but it's
a large number of templates to be sold
in the United States of 1780s 1770s
eighties you know Thomas Paine a great
propagandist and in that way and
contributed to the the beginning of the
United States why do we see so often
people like you mentioned Edmund Burke
and who was he well Edmund Burke was a
Anglo Irish statesman and writer he was
a friend of the American Revolution
complained about the fact that the
Britain the British tried to suppress
the American Revolution and in addition
to be being a statesman a member of
parliament he was a profound man who
wrote serious political works and I
don't know that any of this work had any
influence on our phone
elders but certainly a lot of people
since then have been writing and being
had been influenced by Berk why do you
conservatives refer to Burt as one of
the founders in the sense of political
influential people why do you write
about William McGuffey because he wrote
a broken he wrote books that millions
millions of Americans were educated with
they were schoolbooks and millions of
copies of these books were from the 70s
from 1830s and they were still being
used in the 1920s a Daffy's reader
mcguffey's readers you ever seen him oh
sure oh sure when I was writing this
book I had all of them and the various
editions of them oh sure what they look
like what were they why were they still
popular well they were little primers
and they're easily handled the child
could stand up and read them and was
expected to stand up in class and to
read from them and hold them easily not
like holding an encyclopedia and they
consistent lessons moral lessons largely
the first edition were more forthrightly
christian and the last edition was less
christian and in a way moralistic that
was I suppose inevitable because then
you've got into trouble because not
every American was a Protestant the
Catholics had their own schools and and
so they were not in the public schools
and had their own books is that a
financial decision on his part to sell
more I mean he took the Christian part
of it out someone suggested that might
have something to do with it but I don't
think so
he himself was there
the Methodist minister and a professor
and I think the situation you know that
the world changed the American world
changed the school children changed and
you had to accommodate a greater variety
of interests religious interest there
would be Episcopalians and Baptists and
Presbyterians and so forth and that
might be some quarrels about certain
little Christian doctrine you write
about Martin Luther what impact did he
have on us well Martin Luther of course
had very little different direct impact
on us in the United States you know
great impact on the world however when
he attacked his theses on the wall and
started the the what we call the
Reformation what about Nathan Hale ah
Nathan Hale we called him the way the
prototypical American patriot who in the
very beginning when on this the scaffold
about to be hanged by the British in
1776 said he famously he regretted he
had but one life to lose for this
country and as I say in the book his
alma mater Yale erected a statue it's
there in the old campus they're still on
the weather
typical Yale student recognizes that nor
facial pieces to it but at a time I
suppose they did what about King George
the third
well King George the third was the was
the enemy
we the Declaration of Independence
attributed all kinds of terrible things
to him and which gave us the
justification for
revolting against him you say that
America has never gone to war against
any other liberal democracy yo why did
you make that point then I think it's
true I'm not the one who started the
originator of that was was understood
from the very beginning in fact Hamilton
talks about it in in Federalist Papers
how commercial countries are not likely
to be warlike he thought never lost they
would be but it was understood from the
beginning and there is some truth to it
that liberal democracy devoted to
commerce as ours is likely to trade more
than go to war and the fumes for example
talked about Commerce and the softening
of morals and what he meant by that
among other things for example rather
than fight duels we modern men are
likely to go the court and file for
libel or slander rather than fight duels
it's a softening of our morals we're not
so likely to go to war or to fight over
certain things that's true and I do
think it is true that no two liberal
democracies have ever gone to war
against each others you also say there's
we're the only cars in the world with a
lot our name like there's no other place
where you'd say what you say he's an
American but you wouldn't say he's
unfriend or he's on Chinese why is that
what does it mean to be on American well
in the first place
as I say in the book quoting Martin
diamond an old friend of mine and then
of course the GK Chesterton and the
Englishman who made the same point
before Martin diamond did we speak of
Americanization a non-american and there
are no counterparts in other any other
language and that's not that's simply
not simply a question of phonetics we
speak of Americanism and but the Swiss
don't speak of Swiss ism
that's not simply because that's
phonetically undesirable we are we speak
of these things because as Chesterton
said we're the only country that was
founded on a creed and that Creed is in
the Declaration of Independence when
when we started and said and proclaimed
at the beginning of this that we were a
new order of the ages among other things
we were the first country that was
founded on new principles that did not
that not turn to the rear to its past
and reflect on his history when at the
time of the founding we were new these
were new principles and we were the
first country to deliberately found
ourselves on those principles and that's
what the Chester didn't meant when he
said we were the only country and
founded on the creed that's true at the
time Soviet Union was found in the Creed
too but we were the first and to found
on a creed in that sense have you've
done have you had any political jobs in
your life I've never been elected upon
public office I have had served in
Geneva as the unit's members of the
Human Rights Commission I've been I
served in another special session of the
United Nations Human Rights Commission
and I was a member of the National
Endowment for the Humanities for six
years but I've never been elected to
public office what did you know trying
to understand why the United States got
kicked off the Human Rights Commission
and countries like Sudan and others got
on me explain all that to us
aha yes I wish I could and as a Human
Rights Commission mean anything well
there are those who say it means a great
deal I am NOT one of those I don't think
we ever did very much in my experience
well I was on it
when were you on it in the eighties I
forgot the Ronald Reagan appointment
yeah yeah yeah although I think he had
nothing to do with it
he appointed me into the National
Endowment for Humanities but it was the
assistant secretary of state actually
who appointed me to the Human Rights
Commission the Human Rights Commission
identifies offenses against human rights
in particular countries and issues
reports and complains and so forth I
don't think that it has much to do with
correcting those offenses and they spend
much money it spends some it's not a
it's not a major drain on our economy
how big is staffed there Oh like look
like I remember the in New York hike on
this special occasion I my first day
that I had lunch in the UN ik UN
cafeteria and the prices must have been
set in 1915 hadn't been changed since
you know someone is subsidizing those
those prices those lunches and you know
who yeah the UN is of course overstaffed
and its work in Geneva is sort of plush
LG was a very nice place to work and
when the Human Rights Commission works
in the League of Nations building there
on the shores of the lake the National
Endowment for the Humanities what did
you learn about government or anything
from being on the humanities board for
well six years the task of the of the
end of the age of course is to
strengthen the teaching of the
humanities largely in the universities
and it depends a great deal on who was
chairman of the humanities who was there
when you were there
Bill Bennett and then Lynn Lynn Cheney
the recent in fact he's still chairman
this man Ferris is more interested in
folklore than he is the humanities
properly understood as I would
understand them I think it's very
important for the universities to teach
of the humanities and folklore is not a
part that that curriculum as I
understand it let me ask you this a lot
of authors that sit where you're sitting
have had their books underwritten by the
National Endowment for the Humanities
mm-hmm
are we getting a fair deal on this as a
taxpayer oh I'm only familiar with those
works that were in a way subsidized
during my time on the NIH how political
was it when you were there not political
at all really
we tried not political in the sense of
partisan there was no there's not it was
not partisan was there a certain kind of
history that's being funded versus no
others that are not being funded because
of for some reason well we always have
disagreements and you're bound to have
disagreements as to the kind of history
or who's an important historian there
are complaints now today I just got
through reading one in the New Republic
by a Princeton historian complaining
about the David McCullough's history is
a biography of John Adams one would
think that that's our very popular work
and a very good work and history
historians would not disagree but
there's ill didn't but not funded by the
NEA no no not funded by the early age I
can't identify any particular work that
was funded by neh during my time there
although as I said I do think we'd
funded
works good books that deserve to be
funded do you think it's a good idea for
the taxpayer to spend money on the neh
the National Endowment for the
Humanities in principle it is but I once
testified before Congress urging them to
put an end to the neh in NEA because
everything depends on the chairman was a
chairman at the time and it's very easy
to have a whole project corrupted and
for the Indy Asian the NEA especially
did to fund things that we ought not to
be funding that's more readily
discernible I think in the case of the
NEA in all its troubles and it's had its
troubles have been much more public a
few years ago you know funding these
performance artists truly one of them
who covered herself with chocolate I
can't remember her name Karen something
over there back to your book or their
mama remaining moments we have who would
you say in your lifetime and all the
studying you've done is your favorite
Patriot of Lincoln without questions
without question and is that by far the
greatest American probably one of the
greatest men in history why did so many
people on all sides of the political
event defense not necessarily agree
exactly with that but come pretty close
to agreeing with that you know Lincoln
has has has he had his enemies in one
during his lifetime few were since then
the manner of his death of course
contributed to his status really among
us you know he was martyred but
I I just think Lincoln was a genius and
I used that word sparing me an
astonishing intellect
and with the he understood his own
capacities and tried to conceal then of
course telling bawdy stories and
pretending to be just one of the boys
but much more than that
butcher as I say he was our poet you
know and I've I mean that his words
inspire us and as I say in the book one
can see that in these monuments
comparing by using in the book comparing
the Jefferson Memorial in the Lincoln
Memorial and the reception people have I
go to the Lincoln Memorial with some
frequency largely to see what the
response to it has and that my fellow
citizens how they respond to it and it's
different from them and the Jefferson in
the Lincoln Memorial II they stand there
and they somehow sensed the off Sandnes
of the place in there the walls karbala
the walls the words of the second and
I'll crawl in and get his burg address
and they read those words see the seated
Lincoln before them and it moves them
and I've seen ordinary American citizens
have tears in their eye when they when
they stand there they're in a place
that's it
the effect that he has on Americans
you said you taught at Cornell for ten
years how long were you at Georgetown
I guess 10 years all told but uh I began
to Georgetown as an adjunct professor
teaching one day a week or something
like that and then went there and became
a university professor and I was a
university professor for five years or
something like that which meant I know I
could teach what I wanted to teach and
how often I wanted to teach him what are
you doing now full-time nothing at
Georgetown but besides that besides
writing books anything you're doing well
I think I've got a responsibility to
write a piece and constitutionalism for
the conference at the University of
London in November I'm not going to
London because I refuse to travel on an
airplane but I'll send the piece there
I've got another piece I have to finish
oh yeah I mean I still work our guest
has been Walter burns and here's what
the book looks like making Patriots
thank you very much